okay great to see you all again thanks
for being here thanks for coming back
for another round of this I'm not sure
why you do but you do so since you're
here let's let's let's have a
conversation I want to begin today by
talking about impeachment just kidding
of course I haven't really followed that
story for about four weeks so instead I
want to talk about everyone's favorite
socialist Alexander occasion Cortes she
was she was speaking being interviewed
for an MLK Day event on Monday and had a
few things to say that have provoked
conversation and consternation I want to
go over what she said and my take on on
it might not be entirely what you expect
there's a point I want to make about
about this about her about what she's
saying about what all of the socialist
and the Democrat Party are saying that
maybe hopefully is a little bit more
nuanced then you know they're stupid in
bed which which they might be but I want
to go I want to go deeper than that and
and have a fuller conversation that so
first let's listen to a clip of this
here she is talking again their favorite
subject of course the evil terrible
billionaires listen to this sat on a
couch while thousands of people were
played modern-day slave wages and in
some cases real slave real modern-day
slavery
depending on where you are now in in
terms of food production mm-hmm
you made that money off the backs of
undocumented people mm-hmm you made that
money off of the backs of black and
brown people being paid off a living
wage under a living wage you made that
money off of the backs of single mothers
and all of these people who are
literally dying because they can't
afford to live and so no one ever makes
a billion dollars hmm you take a billion
dollars and I'm not here to villainize
and to say billionaires are inherently
morally corrupt but they are I think
there is a case but um but it's not it's
not to say that it's to say that this
system that we live in life in
capitalism always ends in billionaires
if you don't do it someone else will
right yeah she's not trying to
villainize as she would never do that
billionaires are useless lazy thieving
slave drivers that are killing people
but she's not trying to villainize and I
don't mean to villainize I mean that
they're you know they're just I would
never villainize those slaving scumbags
I would never do that never know so what
we have here is always from AOC is a
gross oversimplification a cartoon that
she is drawing for us it's the same
cartoon that Bernie Sanders draws that
Elizabeth Warren draws that all
Democrats draw to some extent this
cartoon were you could almost imagine in
your head you can imagine in your head
the image that they have in their head
which is of of a
you know a billionaire with an evil grin
chomping on a cigar big potbelly you
know holding a huge bag of money with a
dollar sign on it
and laughing maniacally as he watches
his destitute enslaved employees dying
on the factory floor that's that's the
image that they are painting and that's
what they want us to take away from it
AOC says that billionaires sit on their
couch and don't make anything they just
sit on their couch that's what she
thinks billionaires do sit on their
couch all day now it's true that that
billionaires probably have nicer couches
to sit on so you know who wouldn't love
to sit on a billionaires couch but I'd
wager that they spend less time sitting
on the furniture in their home than the
average person far less I would wager
that the average billionaire spends a
lot less time sitting on his expensive
expensive couch then you spend sitting
on your cheap one or that I spent
sitting on my cheap one you don't become
a billionaire by sitting on your couch
that's not how billionaires are made
despite what we are told by aoc and
Sanders and others that's not how you
make a billionaire by just putting
somebody you don't just plunk somebody
on the couch and who they're a
billionaire now unless you were born
into it okay if you inherited your
billions then then fine yeah you could
inherit it just by sitting on the couch
but Bill Gates didn't inherit his
billions Jeff Bezos didn't inherit his
billions Elon Musk didn't inherit it
Mark Cuban didn't Peter Thiel didn't
Mark Zuckerberg didn't inherit billions
of dollars on and on I mean basically
any of the actual billionaires that come
to mind any of the actual people who are
billionaires that we know of that come
to mind when you say billionaire those
people they didn't inherit the money
they they did in fact earn it they all
started off with far less than a billion
dollars some of them had more than
others but they started off with a lot
less than a billion and then they had a
billion and then they had a lot more
than that
how did they earn it well most of the
names I just mentioned got there got to
the point of being a dreaded billionaire
by founding or helping to found a
business that became very very very very
very successful and how do you get a
business to be that successful by
sitting on the couch really by
exploiting slave labor no that's that's
not it either
and I'm not denying by the way that
there are corporations that do
essentially exploit slave labor but that
happens later it doesn't begin that way
so how do you get there well it takes
for one thing an insane amount of work I
mean these guys have all I would say
worked longer are hours longer days and
endured more professional pressure than
most of us will ever experience that's
the fact and this is what a o'seas
black-and-white cartoon version doesn't
account for can't account for can't
admit those those you know those evil
billionaires are extremely smart
extremely hard-working extremely
innovated innovative and that's how they
got where they are she can't admit that
and her version of the world can't
account for that it's not just
circumstance okay put the average person
put me let's say in Elon Musk's
circumstance going back to the beginning
from from birth am I gonna make a bill
you know I'm you know you're taking me
you're putting him in his in his
situation from birth do I get to make a
billion dollars probably not because I
don't have his mind or his work ethic or
any of the other things that make him a
unique person put me and Mark Zuckerberg
position from birth do I go on to make
billions and billions of dollars on a
website probably not
as much as a OC says she doesn't want to
villainize her whole worldview her her
her whole shtick depends on villains
ation she cannot admit that these people
had all earned their money so that they
have any skills any abilities certainly
any virtues that the average person
lacks she says you don't make a billion
you take a billion well that's a really
catchy nice little applause line so if
you say that in front of the right
audience you're gonna get an applause
but that's all it is it's an applause
line if you stop and think about it for
a second it just takes a second of
thinking about it you say what the hell
does that mean yes it rhymes and it
sounds nice but you don't take it you
don't make a billion you take a billion
what do you mean what's the difference
between those two things and how exactly
did they do that how did Bill Gates I
would say made billions but you say he
took it well how did he take it he had
this idea of you know this he presented
to the marketplace a product personal
computer that a lot of people really
liked and wanted to buy and then he made
a lot of money off of it now yes that is
a that's a that's a that's a very
whittled down version of that story but
that's yeah and it's it's essential
ingredients that's what it was he had a
product that a lot of people really
wanted and they bought it and he made a
lot of money you're saying he took it he
didn't make it so we what he forced the
people to buy it here's a fact if nobody
wanted to buy a Microsoft computer
Bill Gates wouldn't be a billionaire but
they wanted to buy it so he is so you'd
had to say that he didn't make it he
took it you'd have to argue that he
forced people to what he had he'd put a
gun to their head no see that's what the
government can do see everything she's
sang about billionaires is actually true
of the government the government doesn't
make money they take it they take the
money from you by force if you don't
give it to them they can put you in jail
okay that's what taking money looks like
and they don't have to do anything for
it actually if
there are a whole lot of bureaucrats in
the government who essentially just sit
on a couch really don't do anything you
could erase their job from existence and
nobody would notice okay if you erased
Bill Gates from existence starting back
in the 80s though the whole hitch things
would look different things would look
very different we would notice the
difference not to mention an entire huge
very influential and significant company
wouldn't exist probably without them but
so many positions in government you
erased those positions nobody would know
you continued your life you would never
know that that that position doesn't
exist entire departments of the
government you could do away with and
nobody would notice because they don't
really do anything that is something
that is possible in government it is
possible I mean talk to someone who
works in government or has worked in
government and they'll tell you it is
possible to work in government and
really just do nothing it's not really
possible if you're gonna be a successful
business person so it doesn't make any
sense you know if what a OSI is is left
to claim she's left to make the really
psychotic claim that anyone could have
started a billion-dollar business in
their garage like Bill Gates anyone
could have done that in the right
circumstance in fact
I guess you would say we all did do it
Bill Gates into it
he didn't make Microsoft that's not his
we all did it somehow he didn't do
anything
he just sat on his couch we did it
society did it so we all own it not him
that's her claim and again its psychotic
and not only that but morally repugnant
not just intellectually vacuous but
ethically and morally repulsive on top
of it and it's also greedy as much as
she wants she accuses others of greed in
the billionaires of greed
she is exhibiting it herself and and
engendering greed herself by encouraging
people to look at a successful
businessperson and people who did
nothing to contribute and say that's
mine I deserve a piece of that what the
hell did you do for Microsoft you didn't
do anything you don't deserve any of
that you did absolutely nothing I did
absolutely nothing to contribute to the
success of Microsoft other than buying
some of their products which gives me a
right to the product that I bought but
that's it so there's a lot of greed
there as well
but with that said here's the part this
is the point that maybe not everyone is
going to agree with at least the
listeners of this show I do have a point
to make on the other side of the
discussion because there is
oversimplification that happens I think
on the other side when we talk about
this sort of thing and I want to talk
about that but first a word from honey
listen speaking of buying things
everybody shops online right let's
that's how we all buy everything and
certainly how I buy most things these
days well I'm telling you if you're
buying stuff online without honey
there's just no excuse you're leaving
money on the table you may as well
literally be burning your money you
might as well just do that because it's
the same thing honey is a free browser
extension that automatically finds the
best promo codes whenever you shop
online this means you always get the
best deals without even trying on over
20,000 sites Amazon Target Best Buy you
know all the big sites say it's it's
included in all that I've been using
honey for weeks myself now I've saved I
don't even know how much I've saved a
significant chunk of money and I just
ordered for example a new blender which
by the way has been life-changing I'm
the smoothie King now you gotta I mean
if is one of the most essential kitchen
items is to have a nice blender and I
don't know so many kitchens in America
are deprived of it not on how they I
mean once you have anyway that's not the
point I'm not selling a blender i but
the point is I got the blender and I
saved a lot of money using honey honey
has found it's over ten million members
over a billion dollars in savings honey
supports over 20,000 stores online and
it's got over a hundred thousand
five-star reviews on the Google Chrome
Store so you don't have to take my word
for it you just go look at what the
users are saying about it if you're
buying gifts whatever it is then you
need honey and and if you're not then
you probably know someone who is so do
them a solid tell them about honey honey
can help make sure that you're getting
the best price for whatever you're
buying it's free to use and installs in
just two clicks get honey for free at
join honey calm slash Walsh that's join
honey calm slash Walsh okay so a OC
Warren Sanders etc they demonize
billionaires and they paint a picture of
the world that is disconnected from
reality but a word of caution I think
for conservatives I think we make a
mistake when we do nothing but wave off
and dismiss and I see this too often
where we wave off and dismiss concerns
about the exploitation of workers and
the plight of poor people who are
essentially screwed by the circumstances
they're born into we make a mistake when
we act like anyone can just bootstrap
their way into the American Dream when
we act like the free market is entirely
free for everyone when we act like luck
has nothing to do with it and I think
sometimes we are guilty of that kind of
simplification the left has a simplistic
certainly simplistic narrative where
billionaires are evil and we're all
their slaves okay well that's not true
there's no nuance there there's no
attempt to understand there's no thought
put into it and that's not good but and
we can't have a conversation that way
you know the way that AOC opens the
conversation about income inequality or
whatever we're talking about it's just
there's we can't you've begun by
accusing all rich people of being slave
owners and so where can we go from there
but we don't want to respond to that
with our own oversimplification and this
is what most debate in America these
days consists of one side oversimplifies
demonizes villainize is the other side
does the same in the other direction and
nothing is accomplished so what I notice
on the right sometimes is an
oversimplification where we say no you
know the the free market provides equal
opportunity to everyone and nobody is
being exploited and if you don't like
your job it's always as simple as just
going and getting a different job there
is this worship of the free market that
you find sometimes this unwillingness to
admit that there could be any problems
at all with free market in capitalism
and everything and and and this
unwillingness to admit that there are
real moral and ethical concerns when it
comes to billionaires living in luxury
and and and buying five houses and
yachts and everything else in other
words it's a mistake to allow the left
to be the only ones talking about the
exploitation of workers the only ones
talking about greed the only ones
talking about the moral implications of
an uber wealthy person owning seven
houses and three private jets and the
rest of it when we react to their
cartoon version of the world with our
own the effect is that first of all
nobody's dealing with reality and sec
from a political perspective we become
the ones defending billionaires while
they're the ones defending the working
class and the poor and that's how a lot
of people see it they think of the
conservatives and Republicans as the
ones who are on the side of billionaires
and Democrats on the one the ones on the
side of the working class that's that's
been the impression for a long time that
a lot of people have had and it's it's
it's not good to put it mildly
politically here's the way I look at it
it's true that low wage workers are are
often exploited by these big
corporations it's true that some of
these corporations do essentially
especially the ones that the ones that
outsourced overseas do essentially use
slave labor it's true that lots of
people are born into situations where
it's not as simple as just climbing the
ladder a kid for example born in the
inner city no father no role model bad
education emotional turmoil crime all
over the place a kid like that you know
he can't bootstrap his way to a billion
dollars or a million dollars he has been
born into a nearly impossible situation
one that you didn't have to deal with
and I didn't have to deal with
we have advantages yeah yes privileges
that he doesn't have through no fault of
his own that's true and you could always
point to some examples of people who are
born in dirt poor poverty and managed to
climb their way out of it and become
extremely wealthy and successful there
are examples of that but for every
example of that I could give you a
million examples where it didn't work
that way
right it's um you know you take someone
like Mark Zuckerberg okay you take Mark
Zuckerberg with his intelligence and
creativity and ambition and all that
and you take him out of his the
circumstance that he was born into and
you put him in I mean if you take him
out of that circumstance is he gonna be
successful in any other circumstance you
put him in probably not now he'd
probably be successful in a lot of
circumstances take him out of his
circumstance put him into mine he
probably be just as successful even
though I you know I didn't I wasn't born
into a family as well off as his and I
didn't have the same educational
opportunities and all that but I'm not
think you know not that far off
comparatively speaking so put him in my
situation probably be just as successful
but put him in the inner city put him in
a trailer park with a meth-addicted
mother is he gonna end up founding
Facebook and being worth 60 billion
dollars or whatever that's probably not
maybe I mean there's a slim chance
probably not there's also a good chance
he doesn't even survive to be as old as
he is now if he's born in a situation
like that and I think we have to
acknowledge that
it's an obvious thing but it's important
to acknowledge it it's also true that
living in a 15 bedroom mansion with just
yourself and your wife and and one kid
and a dog and all your butlers and maids
and having a fleet of luxury cars and
two private jets and a yacht etc that is
greedy
that's materialistic that's vain that's
grotesque that's immoral
you know I admit I have times when I and
I've been traveling and I Drive through
a really really really wealthy
neighborhood and with just mansions all
over the place and one thing you think
is wow these houses are awesome and then
but then you also think these houses are
gross I mean who would live in this you
worry you would you need this castle to
yourself with rooms you never even go in
so I've had that thought right I think
we all have and it is it is very hard to
morally justify living in a house like
that with rooms you don't even use or
see while there are people starving and
living on the street and freezing to
death that's gonna be very difficult to
morally justify and if you're a
Christian by the way it's impossible and
you just can't do it there's there's no
getting around it I mean especially in
the New Testament it's it's Jesus
constantly talking about the the moral
implications of being very wealthy and
greedy and so you know you really can't
get around it
now it's true that Jesus isn't saying
that no wealthy person can go to heaven
or you know the way that it's sometimes
portrayed but certainly you know it's
hard to imagine that Jesus would endorse
somebody living in a 15 bedroom house
so all of that is true right but it's
also true that most wealthy people most
billionaires work extremely hard to get
what they have they have skills and
abilities and a mental capacity that
most people don't possess it's true that
they earn their success it wasn't merely
given to them by circumstance they even
if there are there would there could
have been circumstances where they could
have not that would have that would have
foreclosed their opportunity to earn
that success that's not the same thing
as saying that the circumstance gave
them the success they did earn it it's
true that they employ lots of people and
sometimes they employ people who would
not be employed otherwise you take
Walmart for example with Walmart
greeters now these are people who if not
for Walmart probably wouldn't be able
get a job anywhere it's true that they
when they buy things like yachts to
satisfy their vanity people are hired to
make those yachts and staff them and so
there are jobs there and it's true that
if you have six billion dollars to throw
around you have a right to spend it
however you want within the bounds of
the law even if it's greedy you still
have that right it's also true that
coming up with some limit of the amount
of money a person can make and the
amount of things they can buy and the
material possessions they can have that
limit is going to be arbitrary and
you're going to run up against the
problem of who has the right or the
authority to come up with that limit who
is the person who can put themselves
above everybody and say no this is the
limit where are you coming up with that
limit who says it should be there and
not somewhere else and besides that
limit will have to be enforced by the
even more powerful and wealthier and and
and more wasteful and more morally
ambiguous force called the state the
government so you could take money from
billionaires for the sake of fairness
but all you've done is made the state
wealthier and the state has guns and
armies and and a power to put you in
jail if they want to and to take away
your rights so it's true that Bill Gates
is less of a threat to us his power is
less of a threat to us than the state's
power all of these things are true
seems to me but this picture that I
painted doesn't fit neatly into the
narrative of either side because I think
the truth rarely does but I think we
need to acknowledge this is the whole
picture and decide where to go from
there and and and once you've
acknowledged that then yeah now there's
a whole conversation we had about policy
and about everything right
you haven't early settled any of the
debates that we're having but at least
you're starting from a place of reality
where we aren't pretending that
billionaires are a bunch of of
villainous slave drivers who don't do
anything we're not doing that but we're
also not pretending that the American
Dream is equally open to everyone and
your circumstance and luck has nothing
to do with it and nobody's being
exploited and did all of that we're in
we're in the realm of truth now and then
we can go from there all right if you're
a regular listen listener to the show
you've heard me talk many times of
course about the pro-life issue because
it's the most important issue it's the
it's the defining issue of our time it's
hard to come to any other conclusion
when you consider the fact that 60
million people have have died since roe
v wade it is the abortion is the number
one cause of death in America it is the
you know the abortion industry has
killed more people than any dictatorship
or any tyrannical government ever has in
history and so it's hard to come to any
other conclusion then this is the most
important issue and but we live in a
culture that is has embraced the culture
of death and is going deeper and deeper
into that abyss to make matters worse
you know you have pro-life advocates who
are being targeted by the pro-abortion
left sometimes in very direct ways you
look at what's happening - Dave daleiden
and Center for medical progress how
they're being legally persecuted if you
come after the pro-abortion if you come
I come after the abortion industry your
there's gonna be a price to pay that's
what we've learned and sometimes the
price can be
as significant as that other times more
commonly you know you've got you know
let's look at what happened with ben
shapiro at the the march for life last
year our advertisers were targeted by
left-wing media watchdogs and we lost
some revenue because just because you
spoke at the march for life and spoke up
for the unborn but we're not the only
targets of course live action is one of
the biggest voices in in the pro-life
movement one of I think the most
influential voices and I would say one
of the sort of founders in a way of the
new of the new pro-life movement of the
modern pro-life movement of the last
decade or so and they continue to do
some of the most important work in that
space from raising awareness and and
also education on the abortion industry
industry undercover videos that expose
Planned Parenthood and other abortion
clinics for horrific human rights abuses
and but they've also been targeted
they've been banned from advertising on
Twitter for their calls to defund
Planned Parenthood they've been banned
from Pinterest altogether for spreading
medical misinformation which is actually
just the truth that they're spreading
they've also seen their advertised
efforts and their online distribution
restricted depending on the platform
that is why our daily wired.com members
are so important your membership helps
keep our cameras on and it helps keep
our microphones turned up even when the
left pressures our sponsors that's why
from now until January 31st a portion of
any daily wire.com membership will be
donated to live action with promo code
live action to support awareness and
education around the world on this issue
so join daily wire.com and make your
pro-life voice heard all right let's see
here one other thing to mention before
we get to do some emails you know when
Jackie Robinson broke the color barrier
in 1947 he was subjected to racist
cheers from fans discrimination from
some of his teammates death threats
physical abuse I mean there are many
examples of that one example is in his
first year on the Brooklyn Dodgers a
player from an opposing team
intentionally slid into him cleats first
and put in
gashed his leg open just as a racist
assault because they don't like the fact
that Jackie Robinson was black
now his willingness to endure that kind
of abuse and that sort of treatment and
the heckles and the taunts and the death
threats and everything while blazing a
trail for other black athletes that has
led many people to consider him perhaps
the bravest athlete in in sports history
certainly in American sports history but
here's the news that his reign has come
to an end he is no longer the the
bravest athlete in history according to
the gay sports outlet out sports and yes
that's a thing there's a gay as gay
sports media there's a gay sports outlet
out sports is what it's called according
to them you know forget about Jackie
Robinson there's a new bravest athlete
in American history
Syd Ziegler writing for Al sports calm
has declared that the bravest athlete of
all time the sports figure who best
embodies you know the virtues of courage
and heroism is a biological male who
beat up a bunch of females in MMA
the bravest Ziegler gave the trans Ali
Talon Fox the moniker of bravest athlete
ever in a recent article and I wrote a
piece about it you can find it on daily
wire.com and he explains that the
professional woman beater is quote an
indelible part of LGBTQ sports history
and has open possibilities for trans
athletes and women's sports that will be
felt for generations now why that
requires courage much less the most
courage of any athlete ever is not
actually explained in the article it
also isn't explained how it requires
courage when a biological male with his
testosterone in his greater muscle mass
and his denser bone structure fractures
the skull of a female opponent which is
what this Fallon Fox person did to one
of the opponents that he faced in the
ring left her lying on the mat concussed
and bleeding now one would think that if
there's any courage involved it's all on
the part of the
woman who's willing to get into the ring
with a man and try our best but no what
we're told by out sports is that you
know it's it's more courageous for a man
to beat up a woman than it is for a
woman to fight a man that's what they're
saying and we're also assured that it's
okay for a male to physically brutalize
a female because you know females
sometimes brutalize each other this is
what Fox was interviewed for this story
and this is the justification that he
offered he said I'm not the first female
MMA fighter who's broken another
fighters bones and people will of course
because I'm trans hold it up as this
devastating thing that couldn't possibly
happen if I weren't trans but there are
many different examples of similar
things happening now he's right of
course he's not the first female fighter
to break another fighter's bones mostly
because he's not a female fighter so he
can't be the first female fighter to do
anything because he's not one but you
notice again here as I've been pointing
out for months the the arbitrary sex
versus gender distinction has been
completely collapsed he's not saying
he's not he's not identifying himself as
you know a male fighter who identifies
as female he's saying I'm a female
fighter female is a biological sex and
that's what he's claiming
don't count on Ziegler to grapple with
that difficulty because of course we're
just supposed to dutifully applaud
accepting at face value whatever lame
justification or explanation or excuses
is put forward he doesn't present actual
arguments at all in favor of allowing
men like Fox to fight women because
there are no arguments available to him
there's just there's literally nothing
you could say it is objectively wrong on
every conceivable level morally
ethically scientifically there is
nothing there's not even the semblance
of a reasonable argument that you could
make for allowing Fallon Fox into the
ring to fight women the most that the
other side of the debate can do is make
vague emotional appeals hoping we'll
forget that the women have emotions also
and they probably don't feel too
emotionally good about being cheated and
abused for the sake of the LGBT agenda
but their emotions are irrelevant
we're told just as science is irrelevant
fairness is irrelevant all that matters
for some reason is how this one guy
feels it's never explained why that
should take precedence over everything
else I mean why should the feeling of
one guy take the precedent over you know
take precedence over everyone else's
feelings let alone science and and truth
and everything else why should it
that's not explained it just it just
does what we're told by the LGBT left is
it just does that's it it just does and
and you know his insistence found Fox's
insistence on doing what makes him feel
good at any cost
just same for the man who insists on
barging into the female locker room or
bathroom or their insistence on doing
what makes them feel good what makes
them feel comfortable at any cost is
admirable not not only admirable but
heroic and not only heroic
the most heroic thing anyone has ever
done or could ever do heroic courageous
beautiful you see this is this is the
point here when you've got you know an
outlet media outlet calling Fallon Fox
the man who beats up women the most
courageous athlete ever the point is you
know that's not just that's not simply
pointless hyperbole it is hyperbole it's
several steps beyond hyperbole but there
is a point to it and the point is to
because they know they don't have any
arguments they know they couldn't
possibly justify this so instead it is
over compensation it is it is they hope
that if they scream loud enough and if
they use language that's hyperbolic
enough that you will that will all be
intimidated and keep silent for that
reason or we'll be so impressed with how
confident they are in their position
that we'll figure they must be right you
know we'll say oh well I mean it doesn't
make any sense to me but if he's saying
that he's the bravest athlete ever then
there must be some reason why he's
saying that and maybe I'm just too
stupid to see it that's what they're
hoping but we should not fall for that
trick and III think fortune at least on
this issue when it comes to men and
women's sports and men and women's
bathrooms I think this is one issue
where most people I think have woken up
to it and aren't falling for it which is
great but now the next step is to stop
this crap from actually happening
because if we all know that it's wrong
and we're willing to say that it's wrong
well now the next and then the next
question is why is it even happening all
right let's go to emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
let's see here
this is from grant says hi supreme
leader Matt I was hoping to seek some
guidance for from you I have recently
learned that my girlfriend of five years
thinks Elvis Presley is better than
Johnny Cash she has even gone so far as
to say Johnny Cash is a bad singer
I've been blindsided by this betrayal
I'm not sure where she was brainwashed
by this false indoctrination but I'm
currently working to right this wrong
with this type of false claim be
punishable by death under your regime
thanks for any input well grants answer
your question of course it would be you
know I think that Elvis Presley was
obviously a very significant figure in
American pop culture influential but
who's sitting around is your girlfriend
really sitting around and listening to
Elvis Presley songs who's doing that who
under the age of 70 is doing that I feel
this way about a lot of Beatles stuff
too I can I can appreciate the influence
that it had for better or worse but on
its own this stuff taking the historical
significance aside pretend forget about
that for a second pretend that you just
heard this stuff for the first time and
it was you know it was not Elvis Presley
or the Beatles it's some other band you
never heard of and you hear one of these
songs are you gonna think to yourself
wow that's a great song that's an
amazing great awesome song I don't think
so I mean if you hear Yellow Submarine
and you without any of the background
it's not the Beatles it's just some
other whatever then it was just recorded
back last April are you gonna hear that
song and think this is a work of genius
this is genius of course or not you're
gonna say this is nonsense
this is dumb nonsense and so now Johnny
Cash on the other hand his sound is
still relevant today his songs have real
meaning his songs aren't about yellow
submarine's or for Presley his song you
know just repeating a phrase over and
over again like you ain't nothing but a
hound dog
that's not Johnny Cash and again I mean
if you heard hound dog
for the first time and it wasn't Elvis
Presley it was smell this breast Lee
let's say who recorded this song in 2016
and you heard that song would you think
this is this blah this is whoever made
this he belongs in a Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame no you wouldn't you would think
this is one of the dumbest songs that
I've ever heard in my life
but again Johnny Cash that's not the
case have you heard of Johnny Cash song
for the first time and it wasn't Johnny
Cash it was somebody else with a lot of
history I'm not saying all of it but
with a lot of it you would think this is
a great song I mean this is a great
songwriter even something like one of my
favorite Johnny Cash songs is a boy
named Sue it's not a it's it's it's not
a song with a lot of emotional depth but
it's a storytelling song and he's
telling the story and he's telling the
story really well and and this it's it's
the kind of thing that Elvis Presley the
beat or the Beatles never could it they
couldn't have done that they could have
told a story like that through song in
that way and yeah if you heard that song
for the first time in the year 2020 yeah
maybe it's it maybe it's your cup of tea
maybe it isn't but you would at least
acknowledge that but it's a very
talented songwriter that's been able to
tell this story a very evocative story
with a lot of imagery and you know I
kind of I'm kind of into the story I
want to see how it to be able to do that
through song is is brilliant takes a lot
of talent and so yeah your girlfriend is
she's not just wrong but I'm afraid to
say she is it would seem a bad person
and I think you should tell her that
don't tell her that I'm kidding this is
from Zach says hi Matt this is a common
debate where I work and would like your
opinion on the matter the question is
could anyone truly be selfless in a
particular act some argue that this is
not possible because all of our
decisions grant us some sort of
favorable result for example a co-worker
of mine claimed to be selfless because
he was taking time out of his schedule
to coach a girls softball team he
claimed that volunteering his time and
helping to buy equipment was
act this was argued to be not selfless
due to the fact that he could get some
sort of satisfaction or good feeling by
coaching the team others argued military
service and first responders are
selfless when they join up knowing they
could be put in risky situations the
argument my coworker makes against this
is they have peace of mind and are
gaining satisfaction knowing that they
are saving somebody's life or protecting
people he says they make this choice in
the moment knowing the worst-case result
and therefore are not selfless in the
situation
to counter this I said that if I was in
a car wreck and brain-dead it would be
selfless of me for my family to make the
decision to harvest my organs for
potentially life-saving surgery for
someone else that is unknown I would
have no knowledge of this going going on
while crashing and a person I do not
know could potentially be saved by organ
donation none of these arguments have
convinced my coworker and would like to
know I would like to know your opinion
well Zach if if selfless means
performing an act with absolutely no
expectation of reward of any kind and
with no emotional or psychological
benefit and with no boost to the
self-esteem or self image with no
pleasure coming from it of any sort of
any kind enact which the performer of
the act knows that after completing the
act he will not enjoy the fruits of that
act at all to any degree in any form it
sounds like that's what your coworkers
are saying like that's what a selfless
act would have to be and they are
arguing that such an act is impossible
nobody would ever do that or has ever
done it and so there's no such thing as
being selfless well I I'm gonna I have
some real qualms with that definition of
selflessness
but even by that definition I mean it is
possible so I think you know I guess by
that definition of selfless a selfless
act would have to be something like an
atheist jumping on a grenade to save his
fellow soldiers something like that
because in that case that would be
someone doing something for the benefit
of others
while believing that he is not going to
receive any reward at all for it and in
fact will be obliterated upon doing it
so he is trading his obliteration and
non-existence for the continued
existence of other people and he's not
gonna be around to feel good about it
and his mind so you know I think that
would qualify as a selfless act but
because of course the argument you could
make is is as well if it's a Christian
doing it they think they're gonna go to
heaven and so they believe there will be
a reward and so is that really selfless
so that's their argument right so what
I'm saying is by that and maybe this is
maybe this is what they're trying to get
at what they're trying to argue is that
really it's only possible for an atheist
to be to be selfless because of the the
lack of an expectation of a reward I
don't agree with that I say a selfless
act is is and even you know even because
even in that case even there you could
argue well maybe they're doing it
because in the moment they feel good
about doing it and yeah it'll be their
last moment on earth but there still is
that reward at least so it's almost like
in order to be selfless what they're
saying is you have to be almost like a
you have to be a psychopath I guess you
have to be a psychopath and an atheist
psychopathic atheists are the only
selfless people by this definition
because you have to in order to feel no
reward at all for doing a good Act
you would have to not feel good about it
according to them even the Atheist
jumping on the grenade for the two
seconds before it blows up and blows
them to smithereens he feels good about
doing it so that's a reward so I guess
that's not selfless either so we need to
be someone who has no paradoxically has
no concern for anybody else and thus
doesn't feel good about saving them yet
does it anyway with no expectation of
reward so I guess a robot really in the
end is what you need I don't agree with
that definition I think that a selfless
act is one where you must overcome your
immediate instinct to pursue
self-preservation or comfort or luxury
or profit for yourself in order to do
something that will benefit
one else now that in my view is selfless
in that you have put yourself to the
side right it's not literally self less
because you still have yourself but so
you know you can't take the word
absolutely literally but what it
represents is I think the subordination
of your own interests in favor of some
higher good I think that selfless not
every word in the English language can
be interpreted in an exactly literal
sense in fact many of them can in fact
language in general is ace is symbolic
every word you say stands for something
it symbolizes something and so I think
that's what selflessness symbolizes but
I would agree and I think it is
important to acknowledge that a lot of
what masquerades as selflessness is not
so if you're you know it if you're doing
something that yeah you know at some
level you will benefit from whether
morally spiritually emotionally yet you
have to as I said overcome that selfish
inclination to go for the more immediate
reward a more more immediate luxury or
comfort in that you know you have to
overcome that for the greater good
that's selfless but if you're doing
something that will benefit the greater
good seemingly but really your only
reason for doing it is to benefit
yourself if that is like at the end of
the day the number one reason why you
did it and your only real motivation and
thus helping someone else is a secondary
to it is more like happenstance it's
more incidental then that's not
selflessness I think an example of this
okay an example would be you see these
people online who record these
inspirational videos of themselves
helping the homeless well you see these
videos sometimes right where somebody
goes and does a generous act for a
homeless person and
towards it records themself doing it and
then puts it online and I hate to be
cynical but I would say that is not a
selfless act that's not a generous act
yeah it's good for the homeless person
because they still were helped by it but
the the point of it 100% is just look at
me look at this great thing I'm doing
it's so that the point is self promotion
self aggrandizement elevating yourself
making people you know flattering
yourself fishing for compliments that's
the point the fact that somebody's being
helped in the process is totally
incidental so that I would say is a
selfish act masquerading as selfless but
not every selfless act is is like that
that's a talk about cynical that's one
hell of a cynical way of looking at the
world we will leave it there thank
somebody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]